our shout out tonight to an
investigative reporter in Alabama who
discovered a County Sheriff
who was personally keeping all the
government money he did not spend on
food for prisoners apparently well over
two million dollars into his pocket and
it all started with the tip from the
teenager who moved the sheriff's lawn
and then some deep digging into publicly
available documents sheriff todd
Hendricken quickly denounced the stories
as faked news a political smear over the
past two weeks me my family my office
the citizens vetted wall county have
been targets of miscellaneous fake news
stories but reporter connor sheets of
al.com
says he was confident he got it right
standing behind his stories and a video
describing nightmare conditions at the
Gadsden Alabama jail and detailing how
some of the money for food ended up in
the sheriff's personal bank account but
we know that he kept over 2.5 million
dollars become but we only really have
snippets based on which documents I was
able to obtain the story was picked up
across the state and around the country
and Alabama sheriff was defiant today as
he defended his practice of pocketing
leftover money from the inmates food
budgets he's taken in well more than
$250,000 a year the most he's required
to report shit rich material for the
lake he's probably the only person who
watched Shawshank Redemption and was
inspired by the warden that's who he
seems like sheet says former prisoners
in jail employees told him the sheriff
was cutting food costs with food that
was donated rotten or worse a meat
product that would come in it was kind
of gray and drab and some of them what
some of them called it starfish patties
they said it looked like a starfish once
it was chopped up but essentially it was
wrapped in a plastic wrapping sort of
like a you know like a Roll sausage and
then that brown
and the box that it came in both said in
red bold letters
not fit for human consumption the
sheriff said prisoners should not expect
anything more than three square meals a
day now let me be clear this is a jail
this is not a bed and breakfast Domino's
does not deliver here we don't run to
McDonald's and get these prisoners of
Chinese Big Macs
Wow I admit this guy knows how to run a
prison but he knows his phos food
restaurant say yeah you as he was
describing his meal plan for himself
that's what it sounded like
we're not gonna get you the crispy bacon
later with the cheese and we're not
gonna get you the mac Florrie with Oreo
swirl or the Arby's meat Mountain now
that one's off menu so you gotta ask for
it we're not gonna Darrell
but the biggest reveal came when she's
reported it was all legal under an
arcane state law that makes the sheriff
personally responsible for feeding his
prisoners it's the law I'm not haven't
done anything wrong
and it's in the day if you make a profit
it's yours she's reporting found that
may be true with state money but not
necessarily with the money the federal
government pays to house immigration
detainees at the state level the
governor has already changed the policy
for the state the state legislators are
looking now to push me laws and there's
been investigations launched at the
federal local and state levels so I
think whether or not it's legal at this
time is to some degree didn't decide the
point I feel like that just gives public
officials an incentive to do their jobs
badly like I don't think it would be a
good idea so that firefighters keep any
money they save on water you know for
all the jokes Conor sheets investigation
was a serious look at an often
underreported condition involving local
jails
sheet says he is far from true with his
investigation which last week was named
one of the finalists for the prestigious
Goldsmith award at Harvard University so
a shout out for Connor sheets and his
bosses at Alabama Media Group and their
newspapers in Birmingham Huntsville and
mobile sometimes the real scandal is not
what's illegal but what's legal that's
our program for night thanks for joining
us we'll see you back here and next week